-Chloe Fineman!
-Hi.
-It is so great to see you.
-Ah, good to see you.
-I feel like every time
I see you,
you're in a glamorous,
gorgeous outfit.
-Yes, we were at the Met Gala.
-We were at the Met Gala
together.
And we witnessed Pete Davidson
going to the bathroom
at the worst time.
-Yes, right as
a gigantic marching band
was about to leave.
And he was warned that the band
was soon to perform.
-Yeah, we warned him.
Pete was with us at this table
at this beautiful gala.
They were like,
"The entertainment is starting
in three minutes --" Or, no,
"Next."
Or, "Everyone, please take
your seats.
The entertainment is beginning."
-Yeah.
-And he goes, "I got to
go to the bathroom.
I got to go pee." And I go, "Oh,
no, it's a bad idea. Don't.
Just wait for the entertainment
and then after that --"
He's like, "Oh, yeah.
I got to go."
They're like, "The entertainment
is starting."
He goes, "Nah, I'm just gonna
go quick."
I go, "Okay, man."
-Right.
But it's also the Met.
So you can't pee quickly 'cause
you're in a large museum.
It takes you 10 -- it's 10 miles
to every bathroom.
-Yeah. So he leaves,
and we immediately go,
"This is a bad idea."
All of a sudden you hear like --
[ Imitating marching band ]
A marching band comes in.
8'9" Pete Davidson is, like,
in the middle of a marching
band, like marching back in.
[ Laughter ]
You're like, "That is so
Pete Davidson right there."
Oh, my gosh.
-Shrugged in a kilt, you know.
Yeah.
-How's everything at "SNL"?
Are you excited?
-Yeah, it's amazing.
We're back, and, you know,
it's obviously "pandemy."
-Yeah, of course.
-But light.
-Okay, good. And you have --
And Owen's ready to go?
-And Owen's ready to go.
-Come on, it's Owen Wilson.
-It's Owen Wilson.
-It's going to be fantastic.
-Lovely guy. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know you do amazing
impressions on the show.
I've told you this before,
they're fantastic.
Have people reached out to you
and said, "Hey, I like that"
or "Hey, stop doing that"?
-Oh, constantly.
-Yeah.
-Constantly.
There's never been
a "stop doing" --
At the Met Gala in the bathroom,
Julia Garner,
who was amazing on "Ozark," was
like, "Why haven't you done me?"
Which was nice to be like --
-It's interesting.
"Why haven't you done me?"
I don't know
if I've ever gotten that.
-Yeah. "Why haven't you?"
-"How come you haven't
done an impression of me?"
-"What the heck?"
-Yeah.
You could probably nail her.
You could do a great --
-Yeah, I'm working on it.
It's coming.
-It's coming?
-Yeah.
-I know you got a direct message
from Reese Witherspoon.
-I did, yes, on a mountaintop.
-Now, was Reese on
a mountaintop or you were?
-No, I'll do these impressions
and then it's sort of this panic
of like,
"Have I humiliated myself?"
Or like, "Do they think
I'm, like, awful?"
And then this, like, little blue
check thing will appear
in your Instagram DMs
and it's the celebrity
that you've done
an impression of,
but you don't know
what it's saying.
And to me it's like a letter
from the president.
You know, it's huge.
So, I was on the top of
a mountain in Montana.
Don't ask why.
[ Laughter ]
In the summer,
a ski mountain at that.
Yeah, not skiing,
and I didn't have service,
and I was with my best friend
and I was like,
"We got to go to the bottom
of the mountain."
-"I can't live without this."
-Reese! Reese!
-"The view is all good,
but I need this!"
-Yeah, and she was so nice.
And then I was like, "Whew!"
-Reese liked it?
-Yeah, then we went back up
the mountain.
-Yes!
See, you go down the mountain.
I would do that
for Reese Witherspoon.
Go back down then climb back up
the mountain.
-Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
-I know you have a lot of wigs
as well.
-Mm-hmm.
-We discussed this.
How many wigs do you have
in your home?
-I think at this point,
as a woman,
I have about [High-pitched
voice] 200 wigs maybe.
-I love how high your voice
just got.
Do you really have 200?
-At least 200 at this point.
[ Laughter ]
-I heard a story and I don't
know if it's true,
but that Brad Pitt was doing
Dr. Fauci on "SNL."
-Yes.
-And they needed a wig for that
and they called you
and borrowed a wig from you?
-[ Normal voice ] Yeah, so we
were fresh in the lockdown.
You know, and you couldn't
quite, like, Amazon a wig.
It might not come in time.
Jeff Bezos wasn't there for you.
[ Laughter ]
Jeffrey wasn't available.
So they -- Tom Brooker was like,
"I hear you've got a stash."
And it became kind of a drug
deal where I was like,
"Yes, I do have a Fauci wig."
And then a man showed up
in, like, a hazmat suit
and I kind of, like,
threw it in a bag.
I wig-dealed.
-Yeah, you did a wig deal.
-Yeah, I did a wig deal.
-It ended up on --
Here's Brad Pitt.
-Yeah.
-There he is right there
wearing --
That's the wig. Not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, Chloe.
-Thank you.
-Thank you, Chloe Fineman,
for saving
"Saturday Night Live."
-Thanks.
-You really did.
-Yeah, I immediately smelled it
when it came.
I immediately was like --
[ Laughter ]
And I wore it.
-"It's the best ever," yeah.
-And I mean, he smells great.
-Yeah, he does. He's amazing.
Are you up for some
new impressions, a game
when we come back?
-Absolutely.
-Here we go. We're doing
some cool, new impressions
here with Chloe Fineman!
Come on back, everybody!